your cellphone benefactor denied is
winning officers never because we I
think we just saw a picture there you
work because how old were you there yeah
I'm 27 and Ben's 25 why are you looking
at younger yeah yeah yeah but you know
funnily enough we'd been in the business
for a while then I mean we'd been I got
in the Union when I was 16 so I mean
that's 11 years after getting in the
Union but that still must be such kind
of mind thing I yeah I mean it still it
took a really long time to just process
everything I mean things happen so fast
a you know even though we'd been hanging
around Hollywood for a long time it and
that and that movie Good Will Hunting
you know was five years in the making so
it it happened kind of in slow motion
for us we were anxious to get it going
things weren't moving fast enough but
once all of that happened that happened
kind of overwrought that night must have
sent you into a tailspin do you go crazy
that that actual night did you go nuts
actually I remember I remember very
clearly going back with my girlfriend at
the time and we went to her house and
she went to sleep and and I seriously I
cook about I had a ponytail back then
but but i but I couldn't sleep I was
just kind of still buzzing it and I was
sitting there and I remember very
clearly looking at that award and and
and thinking very very clearly am I
allowed to say a four-letter word on
this trip I literally looked at it I was
alone with it and I said to myself thank
God I didn't [ __ ] anybody over for this
huh and I suddenly had this kind of
thing wash over me where I thought
imagine chasing that and not getting it
and getting it finally in your 80s or
your 90s with all of life behind you and
realizing what an unbelievable waste of
your you know what I mean because it
can't it's got to be you know what I
mean it's not it can't be good enough
right it can't fill you up it will never
if that's a hole that you have that
won't fill it right and and I felt so
like blessed to have that awareness
that's one when he said to learn it
that'll learn it and and because I
wouldn't have known it unless I you know
anyway like imagine figuring out at 80
that would be how and I literally like
my heart broke for a second I it's like
I imagined another one of me you know an
old man kind of going like oh my god
where did my life go what what have I
done and then it's over
yeah what was the phrase was a phrase
that you heard was it in a movie you
heard a phrase there goes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah I said it to my mother this is
this is funny I said that in in the
movie the natural Robert Redford and
it's based on something the baseball
player Ted Williams once said but so his
character Roy Hobbs and the natural says
all I want is to walk down the street
with you know and when I walk down the
street for people to say there goes Roy
Hobbs the best that ever was and my
mother and I love that movie and I loved
Robert Redford and my mother asked me
one day well what is it what is it that
you want Matthew what are you and I said
look all I want
is to walk down the street someday and
have people say there goes Matt Damon
the best that ever whoa that is the most
disgusting
technically James Bourne has urged a
James Bourne Jason Bourne hasn't been
seen since
and Jason bond is fine David I will use
your ponytail to steer while you dine
upon my lady sandwich
she's really thought it through